si je lis et s'il vous plaît oui oui
c'est ici j'aimerais parler à la
rédactrice en chef avait écouté l est
pas là aujourd'hui mais en fait je peux
peut-être la remplacer à vous c'est
pareil
oui c'est pareil alors ça va voyager
vivre notre journal la femme très chic
hl oui vous êtes lecteur non non je suis
fraser d'un atelier rue leblanc dans le
15e arrondissement
que vous ayez acheté notre journal non
j'ai pas si j'ai trouvé sur une
banquette dans le métro alors je vais
lui oui et ça vous a plu
non c'est pas terrible j'ai rien compris
retrouve au machin ménager les savez le
truc respirer la poussière les gadgets
le shopping qui suit encore à wil et
crème grasse dont l'époux qui craque
oui pire le tricot expliqué finalement
je reste plutôt à des femmes
oui moi je serais plutôt sportif comme
genre oui alors comme ça vous a plutôt
déçu ah non on ne peut pas dire ça non
parce qu'il faut que je retrouve
il ya une chose qui m'a drôlement
m'emballer c'est ce fil à ses deux
filles la page 11
on va en haut à droite
la blonde que les cheveux flous la robe
blanche et grise et chips est décrit en
dessous oui c'est un même cas assez
inquiète la travaille chez vous ou en
fin de temps en temps c'est souvent et
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour un
média une chose que j'aimerais oui
qu'est-ce que vous aimez la connaître
comment elle s'appelle elle s'appelle
pervenches bien
c'est pas un an de crise dans le conflit
ac 1 fleur par mark et moi j'ai bien
longtemps qui s'appelle rose marie
pervenche en y allant de travail chez
vous mais je crois que la coke et un
mois c'est une bonne maison bon alors
voilà si elle veut bien sortir avec moi
c'est l'accord alors le samedi soir je
peux puis le dimanche mais vous dirai
pas le dimanche soir parce que le
dimanche soir je me couche de bonheur
parce que le lundi je me lève à 4 heures
parce que je commence à 6 heures alors
si elle aime danser dit que je sais tout
par coeur chacha slow death of europe
pop un certain cinéma mais j'aime ça
aussi alors si elle aime si elle aime
sortir c'est la cohérence et puis alors
en sport en sport entendons nous bien
madame le golf pas trop alors parcours
de natation en piscine
la boxe église par le foot bien entendu
bien sûr qui s'étonnera pas le foot dit
c'est la peur de sortir avec un ouvrier
avec un métallurgiste
dites-lui que ça c'est pas mon beau
costume c'est pas mon beau costume ça
j'en ai un autre la maison un bleu
marine est tellement beau qu'on dirait
qu'il est neuf
ça fait quatre ans que je le joue pas
c'est que malgré mon costume il est bleu
marine ou bien les petites rayures usant
à voix haute on la devine on la voit on
l'a vu pendant paris nice tout comme ça
forcément la confection ça tient mieux
bah oui à qui des loups vous savez quand
je m'appelle à 9 kg - s'agit redire
général lucien mourlon j'habite à
chevilly-larue ça fait loin maintenant
grandi là bas je vais tout ça parce que
j'ai beaucoup d'amis
en cuisine tout ça on sera très heureux
avec perdant quand on aura fait
connaissance
le principal c'est qu'on soit il sincère
madame moi je moi j'ai jamais comme ça
j'ai déjà aimé dans ma vie comme ça cc
c'est le grand amour ce qu'elle coûte
foot quoi bon c'est vrai il ya mon
contrat mais qui vit le jour
il a lutté tournis alors avec une
fraiseuse à faire attention
la france c'est pas de la tarte mais
c'est ce qui m'a aidé en ce moment alors
je tout pour moi je bois plus je mange
plus je ne bois plus la nouveauté alors
là je parle en marchant mais c'est la
tête c'était pas dur mais je peux vous
en détectant j'ai mon année maintenant
ramadam savoir messieurs qu'on se
connaît bien
ap le magicien galicien ramada moins 10
pour ma commission
vous oubliez pas la mienne à moi c'est
celle qui est en haut à droite mais
n'est pas dire ça à celle de gauche
labrune c'est pas la peine de faire de
chagrin à quelqu'un que je n'aurais pas
choisi la main volontairement assez
d'accord la mienne